ja klar ist auch jahrelange u-haft aber
noch nichts bewiesen ist juristen
befürchten dass das jetzt immer öfter
der fall sein könnte für urlauber in
spanien auf den inseln der grund neue
knallharte gesetze die sie alle kennen
sollten
sonne strand und knast der perfekte
spanien urlaub kann sehr schnell in
einer kleinen zelle enden immer öfter
greifen die spanischen behörden gegen
touristen hart durch also es wird immer
hinten nachjustiert und natürlich wird
gerade das was man so als störung der
öffentlichen ordnung und ruhe was man so
als als unsinn bezeichnet da wurde ja
eigentlich immer ein auge zugedrückt so
erleben was auch im ausland das haben
die auch immer gemacht auf mallorca in
spanien um eben die touristen nicht
abzuschrecken man hat so bis in den
eindruck damit ist jetzt schluss der
jüngsten 13 kegelfreunde feier urlaub
auf mallorca das hotel neben einer bar
als sieger eines abends abbrennt landi
13 kegelfreunde im manne knast die
beweislage ungenügend fünf müssen
freigelassen werden einer weil er zum
brandzeitpunkt unter der dusche stand
vier weitere wurden auf kaution
freigelassen die restlichen sitzen noch
ein eine zügige freilassung ist nicht in
sicht man hat durchaus den eindruck dass
die kegelbrüder hier bauernopfer sind
einer harten linie und ich habe den
eindruck dass hier sozusagen alles
ausgereizt wird was irgendwie möglich
ist um hier die acht personen die ja
noch in haft sind um die auch dazu
behalten und da hat man schon den
eindruck dass hier ganz besonders hart
durchgegriffen wird um ein exempel zu
statuieren
brandstiftung ist natürlich kein
kavaliersdelikt aber immer öfter werden
taten die vor einigen jahren noch völlig
unbeachtet geblieben sind jetzt hart
bestraft
zum beispiel einmal saufen am strand
keine straftat eine ordnungswidrigkeit
1000 bis 5000 euro werden hier fällig
zigaretten auf den boden schmeißen ab
1000 euro geldstrafe
blumen im hotel ausreisen wenn die
blumen bis 400 euro kosten ist es ein
sachschaden ab 400 euro 1 fans delikt
der zu einem jahr gefängnis führen kann
sex in der öffentlichkeit
keine straftat bis zu 5000 euro können
hier berechnet werden da es eine
ordnungswidrigkeit ist genitalien auf
den tisch im bierkönig legen könnte als
exhibitionismus gesehen werden sechs
monate bis ein jahr hart man hat den
eindruck dass die behörden da ganz
besonders hart durchgreifen und es in
kauf nehmen dass sie vielleicht bei
bestimmten teilen von touristen
schlechten ruf bekommen dass man so den
eindruck hat in spanien auf mallorca
wird härter durchgegriffen ich glaube
aber das ist absicht und wer erleben
auch das so dinge unter strafe gestellt
werden oder gerade bußgeldkatalog
erlassen werden die eigentlich vorher ja
nicht so hart geahndet wurde und
deswegen meine ich schon dass
tatsächlich dieser eindruck berechtigt
ist spaniens knallhart behörden greifen
durch touristen im visier der justiz die
wilden zeiten auf dem spanischen
festland und den balearen sind damit
geschichte denn jeder urlauber kann im
knallhart knast enden